pierre laurent le numéro un du parti
communiste français est l'invité de
preuves par 3 avec l' agence
france-presse
ce dailymotion bonsoir soit avec nous
avec donc ce soir qu'à telle prigent de
la fp et puis perrine tarneaud de public
sénat
nous allons bien sûr abordé les grandes
questions politiques et économiques à
cinq jours du premier tour des élections
municipales ou fait alliance dans la
majorité des cas avec le ps alors ça
peut surprendre puisque ce sont des
listes gouvernementales comme le dit
votre autres partenaires le parti de
gauche de jean luc mélenchon mais
d'abord pierre laurent le retour d'un
très agréable parfum de guerre froide
après l'annexion de la crimée par
vladimir poutine
manifestement totalement insensible aux
pressions occidentales est ce que vous
partagez la même indignation qui courent
de paris à washington en passant par
toutes les capitales européennes
je pense que l'annexion par park outin
est extrêmement inquiétant elle le
référendum s'est fait dans des
conditions préoccupante parce que sous
enfin avec des hommes armés un peu
partout enfin un référendum qui me
proposait en vérité qu'une solution donc
cet inquiétant bon ceci étant dit il y
as en face aussi des responsabilités des
responsabilités américaine des
responsabilités de l'union européenne
des responsabilité de l'otan
parce que nous avons accompagné une
situation en ukraine inquiétante
on a un pouvoir en ukraine qui est qui
au départ était une révolte contre la
corruption et puis qui est devenu
aujourd'hui un gouvernement dans lequel
il ya des ultranationalistes qui pousse
à la terre à prioritaire mais qui sont
quand même pour certains même il faut le
dire des antisémistes et des fascistes
qui pousse à la confrontation eux aussi
et malheureusement on est moins en ce
moment dans une escalade militaire
inquiétante plutôt d'ailleurs que d'en
rajouter d'un côté et l'autre sur la
confrontation
il faudrait peut-être avancer des
propositions qui brisent cet engrenage
avec par exemple les responsables les
responsabilités sont partagées dont la
situation en ukraine louis dans l'
escalade les responsabilités sont
partagées et par exemple quand on a dit
à un moment donné
dans la situation en ukraine que l'otan
allait jouer un rôle pour accompagner ce
qui se passait en ukraine
eh bien on a on a mis de l'huile sur le
feu alors qu'on sait qu'on est à la
frontière dans une frontière extrêmement
tendu donc par exemple il faudrait
avancer des propositions de
démilitarisation de l'ensemble de
l'ukraine
il faudrait avancer des propositions
pour que on retourne à un processus
démocratique en ukraine parce que le
pouvoir actuel
le pouvoir actuel n'a pas été élu il n'y
a plus de pouvoir et lui en ukraine
actuellement donc il faudrait que
l'ensemble des ukrainiens puisse se
prononcer sur l'ensemble des questions
leur avenir économique
leurs rapports avec la russie et l'union
européenne sur le régime qu'ils
souhaitent etc
on a actuellement une situation
d'instabilité dont l'ukraine tout
entière démilitariser la russie c'est
elle qui fait pression aujourd'hui avec
celles ci sont armés effectivement se
poser d'une manière beaucoup plus
globale la question de la
démilitarisation des relations
internationales plutôt que d'aller vers
la confrontation est effectivement ne
pas remettre le doigt dans des logiques
de guerre froide des logiques de
confrontation qui ressemble d'ailleurs
plus qu'à des logiques de guerre froide
à des logiques de confrontation
impériale comme on en a connu avant la
première guerre mondiale
est-ce qu'il faut toujours invités
poutine le 6 juin pour le 70e
anniversaire du débarquement
écoutez je pense que les l'anniversaire
du débarquement ne peut se faire qu'avec
l'ensemble des puissances
donc vous voyez à l'époque oui parce que
de toute façon il faudra du dialogue
politique à tous les niveaux et c'est
pas aux pratiquants l'exclusion des uns
ou des autres qu'on va s'en sortir
est ce que le contrat des navires
militaires mistral un contrat qui avait
été signée par la france en 2011 avec
moscou et qui est important évidemment
pour l'emploi dans les chantiers navals
de saint nazaire doit être petit d'être
suspendu selon le modèle de laurent
fabius qui met quand même beaucoup de
précautions oui je pense que là aussi
mais je crains qu'on soit dans une
escalade qui ne traite pas le problème
véritable et qui ne contribue pas à
remettre au plus vite l'ensemble des
acteurs autour de la table donc des
puissances étrangères qui va entamer les
navires militaires en continu les
produits vous pouvez un succès non mais
on peut discuter avec ça vous savez sur
les ventes d'armes de la france y aurait
beaucoup de choses à dire sur les cas
présent on vend des armes à beaucoup de
gens qui les utilisent très mal dans le
monde et notamment on vend beaucoup
darmon qatar qu'on retrouve disséminés
dans tout le sahel regard en cause de
beaucoup de choses à dire sur ça mais
dit mettons ces questions sur la table
dans une discussion avec la russie
il faut mettre toutes les questions sur
la table mais il faut aussi mettre les
questions est ce qu'on a besoin par
exemple d'élargir à la frontière de
l'otan à chaque fois aux portes de la
russie est ce qu'on peut pas avoir des
zones qui soit démilitarisé et qui évite
de mettre le doigt dans cet engrenage
militaire est pour l'instant pas
question de suspendre ce contrat vous
dis que non je pense que ce n'est pas ce
n'est pas mon analyse la première chose
qu'il faut mettre à l'eau alors vous
avez défilé aujourd'hui avec les
syndicats et fo cgt notamment
contre le pacte de responsabilité vous
le dénoncez vous le présenter comme une
fuite en avant est ce que c'est le bon
timing franchement à cinq jours du
scrutin municipal
écoutez on sait que le gouvernement veut
avancer très vite qui veut dans la
foulée des municipales précipiter
l'adoption du pacte de responsabilité
il a mis même une pression énorme avec
l'aide du medef est en lien avec le
medef sur les syndicats pour arracher
des signatures sur un relevé de
conclusions qui ne comporte aucune
contrepartie en matière d'emploi donc le
sel au gouvernement qui essayent de
presser le pas et d'éviter le débat sur
le pacte de responsabilité
donc je pense qu'il est important de
prendre une initiative contre ça
les syndicats en ont pris et nous nous
allons reprendre et nous sommes en train
de construire un appel très large de
personnalités politiques syndicales
associatives à une marche contre
l'austérité le 12 avril appareils jean
pierre raffarin votre collègue au sénat
pose une question qu'elle est peut-être
intéressant t il il y avait combien de
chômeurs dans les cortèges ce mardi
contre le pacte de responsabilité
eh bien monsieur raffarin qui ne
fréquentent pas beaucoup les cortèges en
question il saurait s'il y allait
qu'effectivement on y côtoie des
salariés qui ont été au chômage et qui
des fois on retrouve un emploi et
inversement
d d
des gens qui sont au chômage aujourd'hui
et qui n'arrive pas à retrouver
vous savez c'est pas en opposant ceux
qui ont un travail et ceux qui sont au
chômage qu'on va avancer vers la voie du
progrès social
c'est un ajouté mme byrs la droite
opposée les salariés entre eux mais
quand on est chômeur on reste en salles
arrive quand les chômeurs justement le
pacte de responsabilité prévoit un
allègement des charges notamment sur les
petits salaires et il ya une étude
récente qui dit que c'est efficace pour
créer de l'emploi dans le cas d'espèce
oui mais je le conteste absolument parce
que les chiffres sont têtus
on a on a cumulé en vingt ans parce que
ça fait 20 ans qu'on fait ça 397
milliards d'euros d'exonérations de
cotisations sociales
si on cumule toutes les politiques
d'exonérations de cotisations sociales
depuis 20 ans c'est l'équivalent d'un
budget entier de la france et pour que
le chômage record est là mais la
précarité galopante reste très taxés en
france plus que j'ai le raisin européen
avec mais vous savez lire une menace
mais bien rémunérer le travail ce n'est
pas un handicap pour univers ne parle
pas du salaire je parle des charges qui
nous sommes et c'est pas des charges les
cotisations sociales
sassine ans la protection sociale des
salariés or effectivement bien rémunérer
le travail
c'est à la fois payer un bon salaire et
s'est assurée une protection sociale
maladie une protection contre le chômage
une protection enfin alors justement
politique d'allocation famille ou pour
financer pour financer les économies
nécessaires pour financer le pacte de
responsabilité est ce que vous pensez
que le gouvernement a un plan caché pour
l'après municipal dont il va
malheureusement il n'a pas de plan caché
il a dit les choses il va payer
l'addition avec 50 milliards de
suppression dépense publique c'est à
dire de l'argent qui va être pris contre
les services publics et contre l'emploi
public
donc on va dégrader les services publics
d'un côté et de l'autre côté on va
donner 2
à nouveau de l'argent aux entreprises
qui vont l'utiliser pour accroître leur
rentabilité et pour verser des
dividendes je rappelle quand même parce
qu'on parle là d'un plan qui va alléger
35 milliards que les entreprises ont
versé en 2013 les entreprises du cac 40
ont versé en 2013 39 milliards d'euros
de dividendes
d'ailleurs je ne suis pas le seul je
vois que benoît hamon que beaucoup
d'autres dans la majorité commencent à
pointer ce problème que moelle sur
lequel j'alerte depuis des mois ce que
j'appelle le coût du capital plutôt que
de regarder toujours du côté du coût du
travail
on ferait bien de regarder du côté du
coût du capital à dassault répondent en
quelque sorte à vos directement il dit
j'ai le poil qui se hérisse quand
j'entends parler de cadeau au patronat
ceux qui disent ça ne connaissent rien à
l'entreprise d'accord bon ben il peut
être que son poil se hérisse
mais la vérité est elle et elle est
têtue les dividendes ont cru tout ces
dernières années et encore en 2013
pendant que dans cette période de crise
et bien il y avait de plus en plus de
chômeurs et de gens qui souffraient de
la situation et monsieur gars tu as peut
dire tout ce qu'il veut les chiffres
sont là aussi la part des dividendes
dans la valeur ajoutée est maintenant
supérieur à la part de l'investissement
donc nous avons des entreprises qui
préfèrent faire de la croissance
financière plutôt que d'investir dans
l'emploi feng hâtât c'est vrai ça mais
le premier ministre comme le dit thierry
le paon de la cgt en tout cas il est
très très écouté c'est le moins qu'on
puisse dire d'ailleurs il est le seul
quasiment applaudir et peut-être que il
faudrait ramener les syndicats vous
l'avez dit consigne est quand même un
1er mai même sous l'ère des témoins
exemple et je vous dis cela je vous fait
années de la durée des extraits misant
même cela il naples au 10 pas mon vivons
ici quand même y signe il s'y met avec
en faisant remarquer que peut-être ils
ne sont pas sûrs du résultat ce qui est
très étonnant de signer mais ça c'est
leur responsabilité
j'ai pas mêler de ça mais non le sol qui
applaudit vraiment c'est pierre gattaz
depuis le début et d'ailleurs je crois
que les français le comprennent assez
bien il suffit de regarder ce que
pensent les gens de gauche de la
politique actuelle de françois laurent
parle beaucoup d'un remaniement en ce
moment peut-être après aussi les
municipales comme le pacte de
responsabilité est ce que pour vous ça
peut avoir un sens si c'est un
remaniement pour faire comme on
'l'annonce un gouvernement resserré voir
comme l'a dit monsieur gattaz il nous
faut un gouvernement de combat un
gouvernement de combat pour accélérer
dans cette direction évidemment que ça
ne peut pas me satisfaire
il faut totalement changé de cap et prom
il faudrait changer l'équipe
gouvernementale mais pas dans le sens
pour faire une politique d euros pour
regarder faire un pôle it mais ce n'est
pas une question d'homme c'est pour
faire une politique de gauche qu'on ne
fait pas actuellement
est-ce que où il ya quand même des
ministres qui tirent mieux leur épingle
du jeu vous avez cité benoît hamon qui
vient un peu sur vos positions
concernant le magazine l'usiné nouvelle
déclare sa flamme cette semaine pour
arnaud montebourg et on peut lire c'est
le meilleur défenseur des usines que la
france ait connu depuis 30 ans êtes vous
d'accord
écoutez j'ai été il ya quelques jours à
dunkerque j'ai rencontré tous les
salariés de la sidérurgie les salariés
d'ascométal qui dont l'entreprise vient
d'être mais mise en redressement
les salariés d'arcelor de kerk j'étais
l'autre jouera à côté d'agen à fumel
avec les salariés de métal tant que j'ai
rencontré samedi les salariés de fralib
tous me disent arnaud montebourg nous
fait beaucoup de promesses mais nous on
ne voit pas les résultats
et pour cause parce que arnaud
montebourg est tellement aux
communications
mais ça ne change pas une politique
gouvernementale qui ne permet pas de
s'attaquer à la politique du show un mot
sur le climat à quelques jours des
municipales pierre laurent préjudiciable
semble-t-il à la droite comme à la
gauche et un sondage montrent d'ailleurs
que presque la majorité bonne moitié des
français ressentent un dégoût je relis
je crois que les français ils disent une
chose très simple de mon sens que je
partage à 1000% occupez vous des
problèmes de la france et des français
quand il voit pendant une semaine les
des responsables politiques du
gouvernement et de la droite se jeter à
la figure des affaires à milieu de leurs
préoccupations
effectivement ils sont en colère parce
que eux ils souffrent ils attendent un
gouvernement et ils attendent des
responsables politiques qu'ils soient
mobilisés sur les problèmes essentiels
de la france mais là je sens là des
responsables politiques et en sagesse
enquête
la justice enquête et elle a besoin
d'encaisser ce tome
jean luc marchand affirme que françois
hollande était forcément au courant des
écoutes judiciaires de nicolas sarkozy
que vous avez le même la même conviction
oui ou non mais probablement il a été un
moment donné mais ce qui emporte dans
cette affaire c'est deux choses 1 dans
ces affaires c'est que la justice
travaille parce que manifestement il ya
des choses à éclaircir du côté nicolas
sarkozy et deuxièmement que le
gouvernement actuel ne se mêlent pas
d'intervenir dans la norme dans
l'instruction judiciaire et laisse les
juges travaillent et voilà il faut faire
les dons dans les deux cas la réponse
elle est simple il faut que la justice
travaille et que les responsables
politiques eux se mêle de enfin s'occupe
des problèmes n'est pas autre chose qu
était le président de la lfp va nous
rejoindre dans un instant d'abord on va
parler de vous et de jean luc mélenchon
puisque vous formez quand même un drôle
de couple qui s'est retrouvé il ya
quelques jours
pourrait-on dire on va le voir à nîmes
le reportage de faustine saint geniès
l'image est rare et sans trucage
pierre laurent et jean-luc mélenchon
ensemble mais cela ressemble à de
fausses retrouvailles pour la première
et la dernière fois de la campagne des
municipales
vendredi dernier à nîmes les deux hommes
ont fait estrade commune
mais le courant ne passe pas vraiment ce
qui rassemble ici à nîmes
c'est cette liste de gauche qui fait
rêver jean luc mélenchon ou parti
communiste parti de gauche écologistes
et même quelques socialistes font front
commun
boire à nîmes par nous voulons faire la
démonstration que ses positions du front
de gauche et d'europe écologie les verts
avec les autres qualités qui l'ont rendu
là les juges sur lequel sont embarqués
j'ai dévoilé diot a vocation à les
propager
quand même
pierre laurent lui est dans une toute
autre stratégie
il veut maintenir le parti communiste
face notamment à la menace du front
national il y a embusqué
principal point de crispation entre les
deux hommes les rapports avec le ps
alors que les communistes ont fait des
alliances dans de nombreuses villes
comme paris jean luc mélenchon prône une
autonomie radical vis-à-vis des
socialistes est pour lui l'occasion
ce sera les européennes après les
municipales on va démarrer puis c'est
mon intérêt conseil municipal quand même
au moins qu'on puisse dire bah on tourne
la page on passe à autre chose
passer à autre chose faute de quoi le
front de gauche est menacée d'implosion
voilà après ces images qui vous rappelle
quelques souvenirs récents nous
accueillons qu'un très beau meeting à
nîmes il y avait 1000 personnes entre
vos deux avec mélenchon ça va être un
petit peu le froid quand même qu'à tel
prison peut témoigner elle était sur
place devant soi quelles seraient vos
questions à notre échelle le disait
drôle de couple effectivement les
retrouvailles étaient un petit peu
froide tendu à nîmes vendredi soir vous
en êtes où avec jean luc mélenchon
finale non elle n'était pas spécialement
tendu où on est et on a maintenant on a
retrouvé un rythme régulier de
discussion on se voit et on se parle
quasiment tous les jours en ce moment
sur la situation et sur la suite des
élections municipales et la préparation
des élections européennes
pourtant lui a l'air de dire que la
blessure n'est pas refermée queue il
attend effectivement la fin des
municipales comment qu'on vous à les
surmonter
c est ce qu il ya aussi un problème de
fond je crois que ce qui ce qui aidera à
tourner la page chez les résultats des
élections municipales finalement tout le
monde fera un peu le bilan de ce qui a
été fait par les uns et par les autres
nous nous avons fait des choix que nous
revendiquons jusqu'à ce jour
parce que ils vont permettre de
conforter le parti communiste le front
gauche comme le troisième réseau d'élus
locaux de toutes les formations
politiques nationales et je pense que c
est lui seront utiles pour mener les
batailles contre l'austérité et la suite
donc je ne crois pas que les élections
municipales vont invalider les choix qui
ont été les nôtres au contraire parce
que j'espérais mais non non je n'espère
pas du tout ça j'ai pas d'ennemis
surtout pas au front gauche et j'en ai
pas d'ailleurs j'en ai pas à gauche le
principe mais ennemis sont d'abord à
droite et à l'extrême droite
enfin les adversaires politiques disons
donc chacun tirera les leçons les
terrains collectivement et on va avancer
avancer vers la suite on a eu
effectivement des accords qui est d'un
désaccord important c'est que nous nous
considérons que le fait d'avoir de très
nombreux élus c'est important pour
défendre les populations et monnet nos
batailles qu'on prend du talent vous
associer au ps on l'agent nommé en
janvier le front de gauche devient
invisible on est en train de s'associer
à un parti qu'on critique qu'il critique
un gars et je pense que la peau la
protection des politiques publiques
locales qui vont mettre être être mis en
cause par les injonctions d'austérité
qui vont venir du medef du gouvernement
de bruxelles de la cour des comptes
je pense que la protection de ces
politiques publiques locales pour le
logement les transports publics mérite
qu'on se batte pour constituer des
majorités municipales de gauche qu'on
laisse pas les villes retourner à droite
et pire à l'extrême droite est
évidemment c'est majorité municipale de
gauche continueront d'être traversés par
des débats mais je pense que nous serons
en meilleure position pour protéger ses
politiques publiques et moi j' accordent
de l'importance à ça et quand on le dit
on peut se passer de toute alliance avec
d'autres forces de gauche je dis ce
n'est pas vrai ce n'est pas la réalité
politique
d'ailleurs nous faisons alliance et jean
luc mélenchon sont félicite avec les
verts anny
et dans d'autres villes que je sache est
aussi une formation qui pour le moment a
choisi de rester au gouvernement
donc nous travaillons avec des forces on
voit bien dans le parti socialiste des
gens qui sont qui sont en débat aussi
sur l'orientation gouvernementale et
heureusement que new delhi - qu'il y en
a il y en a d'ailleurs aussi sur la
liste à nîmes dont tous les deux que
tous les deux nous avons été soutenir
est ce que vous comprenez toujours ce
que dit jean luc mélenchon peut-être
qu'on va vous expliquer par exemple elle
a lancées récemment contre meeting cdpa
a dit mme c'était à paris dimanche au
jeu ne m'appartient plus non mais
écoutez nous en parler avec lui au
téléphone
non mais ça c'est quoi moi je pense que
il faut toujours quand on s'investit en
politique et singulièrement quand on est
investi des premières responsabilités
qu'on ait mis sur le devant comme on l'a
été c'est il faut garder du recul en
tout cas c'est important donc voilà
c'est que moi je ne pourra pas mais
chacun sa personnalité pour venir aux
mines et aux municipales justement et
ses problèmes d'éthique est jean luc
mélenchon accuse manuel vaches de
vouloir faire une grande ratatouille des
étiquettes et de noyer le front de
gauche ou le parti gauche on hésite quel
est ce que vous pensez à la même chose
oui je peux vous avez les élections aux
municipales il ya des il ya des
coalitions différents d'une ville à
l'autre donc c'est très difficile de
faire des additions nationale par
formation politique
donc on a vu parfois et souvent des
ministères des ministres de l'intérieur
tenté par des additions improbable donc
ivre il faudra se méfier de ça dimanche
soir pour lire attentivement les
résultats
il suffira pas de lire les additions par
formation politique
il faudra regarder les coalitions qui
l'ont emporté leur nature donc fou une
lecture un peu plus fine que ça et
effectivement il faudra peut-être se
méfier un peu de ce qu'on nous dira le
dimanche soir du côté du ministère de
l'intérieur il faudra y regarder de près
en tout cas je pense qu'il faudra aider
les électeurs et à y regarder de près
vous y regarder de près vous vous conter
par rapport à jean luc mélenchon est
derrière
vous dites vous mettez en route pour les
européennes est ce que les discussions
avancent et aussi avec vos partenaires
bon je le souhaite depuis des mois on a
pris on a pris du retard bon là
maintenant on est dans la dernière ligne
droite des élections européennes donc
nous avons commencé des discussions il
ya déjà eu deux réunions du front de
gauche
ces derniers jours il y en a une
troisième demain matin je pense que nous
maintenons notre objectif il est clair
c'est d'être prêt dès le lendemain des
élections des élections municipales
je pense que nous devrions y arriver
enfin je vois pas ce qui pourrait s'y
opposer
nous sommes sur la question européenne
en face depuis très longtemps
nous soutenons une candidature commune à
l'échelle de toute l'europe qui est
celle du leader de la gauche grecque
alexis tsipras ce nous avons beaucoup de
bien commun sur la question européenne
je ne vois pas pourquoi nous nous
n'irions pas ensemble aux élections
européennes je le pense depuis déjà des
mois quels que soient les résultats
quels que soient les objectifs au second
tour d'ailleurs quelques est ce que vous
prévoyez vous au second tour des
municipales
moi je pense que il va falloir vraiment
se rassembler contre la droite et
l'extrême droite
la priorité des priorités pour le second
tour sera le rassemblement face à la
droite et à l'extrême droite dans toutes
les circonstances et il faudra pour le
faire que chacun fasse les efforts de
rassemblement qui respectent les
résultats du premier tour qui respecte
les différentes forces mais il faudra
travailler d'arrache-pied à ce
rassemblement parce que très
probablement nous risquons de nous
trouver face à des situations de menaces
de basculement de ville vers la droite
et l'extrême droite
et quelles que soient les débats qui a
dans la gauche qui sont très vifs en ce
moment surtout avec un gouvernement
je pense que ça devrait être une
priorité pour le deuxième fois pour en
revenir aux européennes les discussions
dit avance la place de jean luc
mélenchon est déjà définie on
des petites fuites dans la presse qui
disent qu'ils seraient dans le sud ouest
que ça se bataille quand même encore
pour l'île de france
ce que tout ça est encore en cours ou
vraiment vous attend dès le lendemain
des municipales
non il ya des il ya effectivement des
discussions nous pour ce qui est du
parti communiste aux nous avons sont
deux principes simples c'est à dire que
là il le plus simple serait de
reconduire les sortants dont dans les
circonscriptions ils ont été élus donc
jean luc mélenchon le sud ouest patrick
le hyaric député communiste européen en
ile de france
une députée européenne non encartés qui
est dans le front gauche marie christine
vergiat nord sud est donc et jacky hénin
dans le nord
voilà voilà notre proposition et à
partir de là et bien ce procédé à une
répartition émouvoir à une ouverture des
listes dans les autres circonscriptions
ça discute un peu sur ça mais je pense
qu'on va y arriver à jean luc mélenchon
a toujours affirmé que son objectif
était que ces listes volistes arrive
devant celles du parti socialiste n'est
ce pas qu'a t'elle pas ce que vous
partagez cet objectif je pense qu aux
élections européennes les électeurs de
gauche qui voudront mettre un bulletin
anti austérité dans l'urne clairement
anti austérité et pour une europe
solidaire pas sur une position de repli
et pour une europe des travailleurs
solidaires et bien au 1 bis lé temps
pour le faire un bulletin efficace la
liste du oui donc je pense qu'on peut
aller très haut et dans certaines
circonscriptions en tout cas peut-être
être en tête de la gauche ou est
absolument je pense que c'est aux
élections européennes nous nous avons
nous savons que nous sommes déjà
beaucoup plus haut que ce que nous
avions fait en 2009 les sondages le
disent et on n'est pas entré en campagne
je pense qu'on peut faire un très bon
score si on se met aux compagnes rapine
vous êtes prêt à ouvrir vos listes au
npa
je pense que on pourrait ouvrir nos
listes et de tous côtés
moi j'essaye de discuter aussi avec des
des socialistes qui se pose beaucoup de
questions sur la politique la politique
actuelle qui sont pas d'accord avec le
pack de responsabilité qu'ils ont
beaucoup d'interrogations qui
s'inquiètent de cette orientation
mais effectivement ça peut ça peut aussi
des discussions avec le npa le l'idéal
ça serait que ça s'ouvre de tous côtés
dans toutes les familles de
à gauche pour faire les listes les plus
larges possibles il ya quelques
changements j'ai envie de vous demander
ce que vous saluer depuis le passage du
sarkozysme hollandisme écoutez je ne
sais pas ce que c'est le hall ont
disposé de françois et leurs chants je
sais pas si c'est l'été avait envie de
saluer depuis l'alternance
il y a eu il ya eu le mariage pour tous
il ya eu il ya eu cette avancée et bien
c'est vrai qu'au plan économique et
social c'est la déception sur toute la
ligne et même pire que ça parce qu'on a
donc dans plusieurs domaines l'accord
national de l'ani qui a été dans la loi
qui est un recul des droits sociaux on a
eu un recul du droit à la retraite
on s'oriente avec le pack de
responsabilité vers des choses
inquiétantes donc on a malheureusement
au matière économique et sociale plutôt
de la continuité du changement et puis
il ya eu cette avancée sociétale
il ya eu dans le domaine de l'éducation
soit soixante mille pose de créer
c'était un rattrapage par rapport à la
période sarkozy mais on est très loin
des besoins et maintenant on nous dit à
cause des 50 milliards de dhs économique
on veut faire cela que même ces
postes-là alors que c'était soi-disant
la grande priorité ne serait plus
sanctuarisés donc on a des inquiétudes
grandissent et insolent 10 mhz que
pensez vous de la position des
écologistes avec lesquels vous êtes
associé dans certaines villes pour les
municipales et qui participe au
gouvernement
ce que je comprends de lors de leur
débat et puis je discute avec eux c'est
qu'ils sont ils ont ils sont très
inquiets de l'ordre de beaucoup de
choses dans l'orientation gouvernentale
ils ne sont pas satisfaits de ce qu'ils
n'avancent pas en matière écologique et
je crois qu'ils ont ils ont raison le
débat sur la pollution la montre et
encore on n'avance pas assez vite
ils sont aussi à dont l'or dans leurs
rangs beaucoup de gens inquiets par les
orientations sociales du gouvernement
ils essayent de peser de l'intérieur sur
les orientations gouvernementales
c'est un choix qui leur appartient qui
fait débat chez eux moi j'ai pas mêler
de ce choix ils essayent à leur manière
de peser pour le moment il n'y arrive
pas beaucoup
comment ils vont faire évoluer leurs
positions mais moi je constate que comme
j'arrive à le faire avec des socialistes
sur le terrain avec des écologistes nous
arrivions à constituer par exemple des
majorités municipales ou des accords
municipaux avec des objectifs qui sont
des vrais objectifs de gauche
donc ça veut dire que le combat doit
continuer et qu'une majorité alternative
qui rassemblerait à terme des gens venus
de toutes les familles de la gauche pour
mener autre chose que les politiques
d'austérité actuelle est nécessaire et
qu'elle est possible et ça reste notre
objectif donc une sortie d écologie du
gouvernement vous leur tendait la main
pour rejoindre le front de gauche mais
je leur tends la main même en étant au
gouvernement et je tends la main à des
socialistes qui ont et qui sue qui sont
dans une formation qui sont un
gouvernement parce que nous pouvons
d'ores et déjà travaillé ensemble
nous proposons une grande marche contre
l'austérité le 12 avril contrôle pack de
responsabilité pour contrôler la droite
et l'extrême droite
et nous disons à des verts et des
socialistes venez avec nous dans cette
manière si vous attendez tout le monde
voulait que françois hollande est sans
gouvernement reste au sol
mais il s'est isolé il s'est isolé tout
seul françois hollande qui le soutient
il a il est à 20% popularité deux ans
après avoir été élu président de la
république il a il a tourné le dos aux
gens de gauche les gens de gauche ne lui
font plus confiance
et effectivement il s'est isolé et c'est
à nous de rassembler maintenant ses
forces qui ne se reconnaissent pas dans
la politique gouvernementale pour
reconstituer une autre majorité que
celle là qui mènera une politique de
bush
merci riga tél allez on va s'intéresser
maintenant au combat électoral
particulier qui se déroule en ce moment
en seine-saint-denis un département où
le communisme municipal comme on dit un
père leur en a encore quelques lettres
de noblesse mais va-t-on bientôt dire
avait puisque claude bartolone l'homme
fort du département qui est également le
président de l'assemblée nationale a
décidé
manifestement de ne pas vous faire de
cadeaux on en parle avec perrine
tarneaud dans un instant après ce
reportage sur place de ce financement
bonjour madame
vous allez vous allez bien il fait
partie de ces jeunes loups socialiste
surnommés les barthes aux boys mathieu
hanotin 35 ans jeune député et vice
président du conseil général connaît
bien le département de seine saint denis
aujourd'hui il est à la conquête de ce
bastion communiste kke et la ville de
saint denis
poussé par le président de l'assemblée
nationale claude bartolone
oui j'ai des affinités politiques
particulières avec le bartolone oui on
partage le même projet politique pour la
seine-saint-denis oui on a travaillé
ensemble au conseil général oui on
travaille ensemble à l'assemblée
nationale oui je suis fier notre pôle
marketing chez chaque jour pour
promouvoir partout il le peut le
département la seine saint denis face à
lui soutenu par marie george buffet
didier paillard maire communiste sortant
il regrette qu aucune alliance n'était
possible avec les socialistes et y voit
là la patte de claude bartolone se sert
de ce que ces jeunes militants je
rejoins de députés pour pour aller à la
conquête de
de nos vignes se manifeste par sa
présence régulière enfin à lui même il
nous honore tous les semaines de sa
présence d'une façon d'une eau dans des
événements qu'on ne fera rien à voir
avec la vie politique
claude bartolone omniprésent mais qui
fuit les médias
son idée poussé le parti communiste or
de seine-saint-denis alors que sur les
40 communes que compte le département
seuls 11 sont encore sous le giron du pc
une offensive inédite dans ce
département historiquement communiste
jugée agressive pour leurs armes est
rude et yves département il sait pas de
la concurrence c'est d'extermination
c'est le couteau du boucher socialiste
qui veut égorger les quelques
communistes qui reste dans ce
département il se présente presque
partout contre c'est vrai à saint denis
c'est vrai à bagnolet c'est vrai à
aubervilliers c'est vrai à saint-ouen
c'est vrai même à villepinte enfin donc
presque toutes les communes que détient
le parti communiste le parti socialiste
se présente contre pour les éliminer
comme ils l'ont fait du conseil général
l'enjeu caché de ces municipales en
seine saint denis serait le grand paris
claude bartolone ne cache pas son envie
de diriger la future métropole
s'il ne joue qu'un rôle secondaire dans
ces municipales lui qui n'est candidat
qu'à un modeste poste de conseiller
municipal au pré saint gervais le patron
du département comme on l'appelle place
ses pions
voilà donc pour claude bartolone est ce
qu'on appelle maintenant les bars tomboy
bonsoir perrine tarneaud questions sur
ce thème à notre invité vous sentir
laurent est ce que vous reprenez le
terme de jean christophe lagarde
convient d'entendre dans ce reportage il
parle d'extermination des communistes
dans le département de la
seine-saint-denis extermination par le
parti socialiste et par claude bartolone
mais ils on parle en connaissance de
cause parce qu'il a pratiqué la même
chose dans la ville de drancy aux
alentours donc effet il ya d'ailleurs
des connivences des connivences
dangereuse en seine saint denis vous
avez pour éliminer les comédies et par
exemple pour éliminer les communistes on
voit parcours parfois se construire des
coalitions extrêmement extrêmement
inquiétante
récemment le le front national qui n'a
pas réussi à présenter une liste à sony
a déclaré qu' il fallait éradiquer
l'équipe paillard le maire le maire
communiste de saint denis en disant peut
un peu en porte il eu chez le chirurgien
est socialiste et socialise donc
effectivement on voit des parfois des
coalition contre nature pour essayer
nous a fait bien mais je pense que la
situation ne s'y prête pas en ce moment
parce que les populations seine saint
denis ont besoin de solidarité
elles ont besoin de politique
protectrice et je pense que les
opérations qui sont menées actuellement
dans quelques villes inspiré par claude
bartolone je crois qu'elles vont échouer
cette fois ci en seine saint denis quel
est l'objectif de claude bartolone
c'est d'avoir à une hégémonie
sur le département de la seine c'est au
delà et au de l'info il faut il faut
croire oui il faut croire que c'est une
c'est un objectif qui possède qui était
assez loin mais qui est assez loin
pourtant de l'intérêt des populations
mais prônons la ville sony parle on
concrètement cette ville qui a été
touchée il ya plusieurs décennies par
une très grave d industrialisation
aujourd'hui c'est une ville en plein
développement c'est une ville qui a ré
industrialiser tout plaine commune
c'est une ville qui entoure ce cadre de
france fait du développement c'est une
période son centre sur place à ben c'est
parce que il connaît pas bien la ville
de saint denis si elle fait confiance
justement aux équipes qui comptent qui
ont conduit la ville c'est parce que il
y à danser dans ces villes des
politiques de solidarité qui les protège
des politiques dans les cantines
scolaires des politiques de
développement de l'emploi des politiques
de service public ultra des députés
socialistes sur les marchés elle a aidé
à il le dit aux électeurs qui rencontra
est acquis et distribue non seulement
des écharpe rose mais ces tracts
évidemment maintenant faut tourner la
page assez durs et les communistes
oui mais ça ça c'est une rhétorique qui
ne ressemble pas beaucoup un homme de
gauche
voilà c'est une rhétorique on entend
beaucoup chez chez des hommes de droite
qui vole qui veulent se débarrasser des
fois des communistes et des fois des
socialistes et or dans ces villes là ce
dont nous avons besoin c'est du
rassemblement de toutes les forces de
gauche ne voulons pas une hégémonie
communiste en seine saint denis qui
n'existe d'ailleurs voir passer voulons
nous voulons que les forces qui sont à
gauche dans ce département s'unissent
pour protéger les populations contre les
politiques de spéculation et politiques
de chômage qui m'a frappé dans les
candidats socialistes de ce département
mais aussi haut dans la petite couronne
parisienne
c'est finalement le non-cumul la
limitation du cumul et bien ça attendra
2010 est monsieur nota qu'on a vu dans
le reportage est déjà député et vice
président du conseil général
il se présente comme tête de liste il ya
bruno le roux aussi dans le département
qui se présentent en troisième place par
en tête de liste no le parti socialiste
finalement fait voter une loi sur la
limitation du déficit mais qui demande
parce que b
très nourris quand on est plus
préoccupés par l'intérêt général mais
seulement par les ambitions personnelles
des uns des autres et de jeunes députés
qui parce qu'ils ont été élus à la
faveur d'une vague rose en législatif
pensent que tout leur est permis
on voit on voit ce que ça donne et
d'ailleurs on a le même cas en seine
saint denis lejeune député socialiste
élu razzy hammadi s'élancer départ c'est
lent c'est long c'est pareil n'importe
comment dans la bataille à montreuil va
finir et il va finir si nous écoute tu
ne feras pas la peau c'est ça ça me
paraît clair je pense que en seine saint
denis il ya une volonté
je pense qu'il ya une crise je lui dis
clairement il ya une volonté des
populations de redévelopper de
redévelopper l'influencent du parti
communiste du front de gauche et de la
gauche toute entière parce que nous nous
servons la gauche on va parler un petit
peu la pollution en ile-de-france avec
l'application native de la circulation
alternée hier à paris est-ce que selon
vous c'est une décision politique et
électoraliste avant tout non c'est une
décision il ya un vrai problème
il ya un vrai problème de pollution sur
l'innocence
il ne devait pas ce weed ce week-end
donc effectivement là c'est un coup une
fois on nous dit ça a été utile moi j'ai
pas le moyen de le vérifier que ça à
faire descendre immédiatement la
pollution mais on sait qu on traitera
pas le problème dans la durée avec des
coups de stricker difficile
d'anticipation politique il ya un
déficit depuis très longtemps on a on a
pris 20 ans de retard en développement
des services pu les transports publics
en ile de france
on a laissé depuis 20 ans développe le
fret sur la route là l'île de france
comme malheureusement toutes les régions
de france est envahie de camions et
qu'on ne développe pas le fret
ferroviaire il ya des grandes gares de
fret ferroviaire en ile de france à
villeneuve saint georges à blanc mesnil
qui ne sont pas développées comme elle
le devrait
alors qu une écotaxe en france
je vous raconte une chose je suis allé
visiter rungis il ya quelques jours
et bien il y a des lignes de fret qui
viennent du sud de la france pour amener
les fruits et légumes
c'est bien non si elles servent mais la
sncf vont fermer une des deux si on
supprime cette ligne eh bien on aura des
camions supplémentaires que là que le
gouvernement s'occupe de ça elle a
d'abord été organisé le fret voilà voilà
une mesure concrète voilà en ile de
france et qui sera celle-là pérenne
durable défendre les lignes de chemins
fr qui amènent des fruits et légumes à
rungis tous les matins plutôt que de
transporter ses fruits les gars vous
allez gagner depuis perpignan compte
abonné mais on sait jamais à quelle
heure il arrive c'est être un parent etc
tandis n'avez qu'à lyon tandis qu'alice
et d'une grande fille habite vous
souhaitez visiter les la pollution des
camions vous pourquoi vous parlez pas de
la pollution du diesel des voitures
diesel aussi il y à aussi il ya aussi un
problème avec mais ça pour régler ce
problème là il faut faire évoluer le
parc automobile
il faut mais ça pareil c'est un plan de
transition durable il faut il faut
travailler avec les constructeurs
automobiles faire évoluer le parc
automobile
et puis encouragé les les automobilistes
à acheter des plus taxés
non oui mais justement c'est pas comme
ça qu'il faut prendre le problème parce
que là haut culpabiliser toujours les
mêmes c'est comme hier on a on a mis la
main à des gens qui essayaient d'aller
travailler avec l'envoi n'en par ses
services mais certains pouvaient
peut-être faire aux trois mots je sais
pas mais mon soit dit entre nous petite
anecdote sur la journée d'hier
il y avait beaucoup de contrôles à la
porte de montreuil à la porte de
bagnolet où pourrais pas passer au
travers
oui mais pas à porte de saint cloud à
porte d'auteuil avant émission ce lien
dans les contrôles hier il n'y avait pas
de contrôle à la porte d'auteuil à la
porte de saint-cloud par contre vous
pouviez pas rentrer dans pareil avec une
voiture à la porte de bagnolet
mais bon sa mise à part je sais pas
pourquoi d'ailleurs je pose une question
j'aimerais la question c'est ce que j'ai
pas de pression j'ai pas l'impression
que les voitures polluent moins à
l'ouest de paris calèches à paris elle
veut éradiquer le diesel est ce qu'elle
en a les moyens
mais mais il faut encourager les gens on
les a encouragés à acheter des voitures
diesel et maintenant on va les matraques
et c'est pas comme ça qu'on va je ne
prends même nous faisons évoluer le parc
par exemple on peut le faire très vite
évoluer dans tout le parc des autobus
des voilà tout ce qui est maîtrisée par
la puissance publique est tous les parcs
publics peuvent évoluer en ile-de-france
en training and i'll go et cécile duflot
c'était ce week-end sur la pollution est
ce que votre avis anne hidalgo ce moment
elle fait preuve d'un peu de fébrilité
là en cette fin de campagne
elle a peur de l'abstention importante à
gauche qui pourrait la pénaliser de
fébrilité dont c'est pas le sait pas
l'impression gg participer au meeting
avec elle dans le 20e arrondissement qui
est mon arrondissement je n'ai pas senti
une candidate fébrile il ya une campagne
qui semaine à paris qui est de mon point
de vue une bonne campagne qui avance des
propositions précises nous avons beau
nous avons joué un rôle extrêmement
utile pour que les propositions soient
précises notamment sur la question du
logement social des transports publics
des halles à nos militaires je pense que
mes mais le problème de la mobilisation
électorale se pose à paris comme
ailleurs à cause d'un climat national
qui effectivement qui effectivement pas
très pas très bon et tu as une analyse à
tort anne hidalgo d'être réticente à
l'éventuelle fusion de ces listes de vos
listes avec celles du parti de gauche
elle dit ça ne serait pas cohérent ou
écouter ou moi je pense que je l' ai dit
tout à l'heure au 2e tour il faudra
donner la priorité au rassemblement
contre la droite et l'extrême droite
c'est donc pour moi ça ça veut dire le
rassemblement maximum arnoux bon
deuxième tour du tout ce qui se dit non
non non attendez je dis il faut la
logique d'ensemble doit être le
rassemblement maximum pour faire face à
la droite et à l'extrême droite et moi
c'est ce que je souhaite
voilà pour venir des primes au premier
tour dans des configurations qui sont
différents et puis au deuxième tour on
se rassemble pour battre la droite et
l'extrême moi et je pense que ça
continue de fonctionner et d'être
efficace allez qui a encore une occasion
de dire du mal de la politique suivie et
de françois hollande vont regretter que
les étrangers ne participent pas au
scrutin municipal
mais bien sûr c'est écouter ça fait
depuis 80 ans
les présidents socialistes ont tout fait
cette promesse et l'orangé une fois élu
c'est pour moi cet indice est déjà lourd
celle que vous avez salué pour sur le
mariage entre un président de gauche ce
n'est pas très très ambitieux comme
aimant et lorsque si une réforme
sociétale
ça commence à faire peur à la mouche
alors la houle effectivement on est mal
barré voilà qui est dit c'était clair et
net depuis le début de cette émission
merci perrine merci pierre laurent je
retrouve dimanche soir à partir de 19
heures sur la chaîne public sénat avec
lcp-assemblée nationale pour bien sûr la
soirée des municipales la semaine
prochaine lors de l'entre-deux-tours
terrines et bien il y aura deux preuves
par 3 mardi et mercredi a très vite